well breaking news here at sky news the
u.s pentagon press secretary has
confirmed an explosion outside kabul
international airport let's get more on
that now for you from sky's foreign
affairs editor deborah haynes she joins
me now uh deborah what more can you tell
us
well details are very thin at the moment
we're waiting for more um i spoke to a
british defense source who said that
they were aware of reports of this
explosion and and possibly gunfire um
there will be more details soon and as
soon as we get them we will bring them
to you but this is um an attack it seems
an explosion at least that comes after
multiple warnings of a an imminent
credible lethal threat of a terrorist
attack outside the airport
the focus of this massive evacuation
effort
british and american officials and
australian officials
urged people to stay away from the
airport because of this terrorist
warning
people are desperate to get on these
evacuation flights thousands remained at
the air outside the gates and waiting to
try to get in despite the threat and now
it seems that
an explosion has happened we don't have
any details yet on whether there are any
casualties what happened what caused the
explosion but as soon as we get more
details we'll bring them to you
and deborah of course um there were
reports that this may well happen that
the threat was imminent and
people were asked not to go
to the airport unless they actually had
paperwork
this is all of course unfolding as the
evacuation effort carries on
it really is uh underlining the sense of
desperation i spoke to one former
interpreter for the british military he
is at the airport he is outside the
airport i haven't been able to reach him
he's outside the airport with his wife
with his three-month-old baby daughter
and with his three-year-old son he he's
been there for five days waiting trying
to get onto one of these evacuation
flights he's someone who has eligible
documents to get him on a flight and yet
he hasn't been called forward he told me
that he was in hell waiting in the dust
with no food with no shelter with his
family and i asked him why did he come
when today when there was this terrorist
threat warning and he the only response
he had for me was the fact that
he doesn't believe he has a life without
um getting onto that aircraft he he
regards the taliban as as a massive
threat to him
and he said to me that he just he
couldn't imagine what would happen to
him if he didn't manage to get himself
and his family on that flight so he was
willing to take that risk and wait
outside the airport in the hope that he
would get on one of these last
evacuation flights many others clearly
felt the same and that's why they did
not they chose not to heed that warning
they don't believe they've got anything
to lose and i think that really does
underline the absolute tragedy of this
that's unfolding the um the british and
the americans were saying that their um
their most their focus on the threat was
regarding a group linked to islamic
state islamic state khorasan um saying
that they posed an imminent threat and
it's not going to be lost on anybody
that this intervention in afghanistan
launched 20 years ago in the wake of the
september 11 terrorist attacks on the
united states to stop afghanistan
from being used as a haven by terrorism
20 years on as this chaotic exit unfolds
a terrorist threat overshadowing it and
now news of this explosion we don't know
yet any more details like i said but as
soon as we get that we'll bring them to
you